the head coach of Oklahoma football
Lincoln Riley calling here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach hey I'm
great I'm great how you guys doing I'm
doing fine where have we found you
you're strolling around this fair city
here in Nashville yeah I am I am I've
got to enjoy this pretty little bit and
I just got back coach Dale getting ready
for the big night
excellent well I mean I'll ask you the
question what are you what are you
hearing I know you've been around Cuyler
and his family what are you guys hearing
right now a few hours before the draft
uh hopefully kind of staying away from
it you know I mean I think you there's
so much talk right now smokescreens I
mean you know everybody's get different
opinion on it so you know it's I got
those down you know before we got here I
mean these things can happen a million
different ways you're gonna be a
first-round pick you're gonna be
somebody's gonna direct you can be the
franchise quarterback and that's a great
thing regardless of where it happens and
so I think all that's just going in to
enjoy the moment enjoy the evening be
excited about you know whoever ends up
with them and the rest of our cows so
who is who is what what will a team get
in Kyler's Murray best you can sum it up
for those who have been hearing the
evaluation about this young man non-stop
for the last 10 weeks yeah I mean a
winner first a great person competitor
and I mean you talked about one of the
elite athletes you know that that Sports
has ever seen you know with you know
guys after tonight's gonna be a
first-round pick in two major major
sports you know it's next impossible to
Putin one and forgot to be able doing to
just remarkable and so they're
breathtaking athletes it's gonna do
nothing but continue to get better
especially as he is able to focus in on
the only one football and I know he's
excited about that and the team that
gets in there they're gonna see that and
they're gonna see that guys still hungry
to improve and it's just gonna be fun to
see the whole thing I'm hope what's your
first memory of the first well play
right in front of you from from Kyler do
you have one do you remember that's the
first one where maybe you thought to
yourself we looked at a member of your
staff and just went okay that's that's
that's the wild play that we were
expecting from him
yeah I mean he had a couple you know
this year I mean some of the the throws
I mean just some jaw-dropping throws
both on from the pocket the move I mean
obviously though he had a couple really
long runs that were just he ever had one
in the Florida Atlantic game his first
start you know we're into the front and
probably about 60 yards to gain 30 but I
mean it was just stuff you know it was
just all things it shouldn't happen and
he just makes some incredible place like
a fumble in a ball against Baylor are
getting stripped the ball falls on the
ground you know every other quarterback
in America just got dive on it he picks
it up scrambles out avoids again for a
third of honk strike I mean he just the
guy can just do things again that you
just you don't count on that shouldn't
happen in ball tonight wha when he's
your quarterback well in a different
game than everybody else
a few minutes here with Lincoln Reilly
as he's here in Nashville for tonight's
draft I loved meeting Marquis Brown
coach he came on our show on Tuesday and
he lit up the room and he lights up
football fields I I really think and
right now we're hearing he's shooting up
draft boards right now I'm wondering
what you could tell us about what you
saw in an marques to get him onto your
squad yeah he's a tremendous tremendous
person I mean I know you're familiar
with his story you know from where he
came from you know and and all he did
you know through the junior college and
all that it's an amazing story you know
walking to or honking to practice really
he was right about the only one that
believed in himself and to see how far
he's taken in such a short time and it's
amazing
I mean he's uh he's a game breaker man
and so he the game's a little different
when he's on the field for you he's got
that you got to count for and I think
he's got that so many teams just that
speed that he not just runs that but
plays the game at it is it's it's elite
and that's a as we've seen in the NFL
with those you know the Tyree keels and
and all the different you know great
ones that have gone here in the last few
years they've been such game changers
for people I mean I think that's been
great for Marquis and something he's one
of those kids like you you know he
appreciates this moment and the journey
he's been on and it's fun to see him be
able to about the
well Lincoln it sure looks like you like
suiting up quarterbacks who have
shoulder chips we all know obviously
about Baker and Kyler and jaylen hurts
now coming in right right now to your
program he's got a huge one and the way
that he has conducted himself based on
on his experience there I'm wondering
what what attracted jaylen Hertz to you
and your program yeah I think it was
just kind of the right place right time
for both of us we were looking to
bringing in an older guy and somebody a
little bit more experienced in that room
and and then he was looking for a fresh
start and then I'd take a place and I'd
seen the success that our guys have been
able to have and and you know I seem to
have fun with different guys different
years different teams and so I think we
kind of both just fit the mold of what
each other was looking for and it's been
a great great pairing so far he's been a
lot of fun to coach our players have
really taken to him and yeah though the
maturity and just the the confidence
that this guy has is off the charts so
then he's a very skilled player as well
so yeah he's been a great addition and
you know excited to see him get better
and continue to get more comfortable in
our system and in our program is that an
appropriate analysis that you like you
like quarterbacks with chips on their
shoulders absolutely not is I think that
I think that position in a lot of ways
sets the tone for your team and if if
you don't have an edgy competitive team
you're probably not going to be very
good and so yeah I think that there's
the quarterback I've got to have a
toughness and an edge about them and and
I believe we've been lucky to have some
some guys that as you said certainly
have that yeah I mean and at least if
you send jaylen to the next level we
won't be talking about his height
that'll be I know that's what we do in
the NFL hey coach I know you run around
town really appreciate you chiming in
and enjoy the night with the Murray
family and everyone else that you were
there with yeah thanks reg appreciate
you have me on both show helped develop
to run into y'all beer I'll be right
there next to the stage so hope to see
it tonight yeah we'll see you there
thanks again excellent
you got it there's a
coach Lincoln why for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app